[Music]
hi susan how are you
great how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
well
i just started listening about two
months ago and
i've really started to try make some
changes and my baby steps have been all
over the place
and
my investments are
heavily weighted into two spots which i
know is not
the way i'm supposed to be doing it so
i'm turning 60 this year and i'm like
holy cow
i'm probably not where i should be
and i need to
figure out how to get where i should be
that's a good question susan so where
are the two you said the two main
investments where are they at where's
your money at in them
well
i have a lot of equity in my home
because it is getting close to
being paid off good um
yeah and of course like i said that's a
baby step out of order
i'll tell you more but and i have
heavily i have stock in my company
and it's privately held
stock
but
owning a good amount of a minimal amount
of in my company pays me a good bonus
every month
um
so it's
it's great my stock has more than
doubled in the three years i've owned
company stock
it's worth right now about 519 000.
what's your home worth
um it's probably worth
uh 600 or a little better look at you
millionaire 60 year old well done
all right yeah and um the uh what other
investments have you got 401k
i do
um
it's only got in it now with the way the
market is right now it's around 160.
good good okay what else
um
my total retirement with some old
iras that i had that have just been
sitting for years
my total total retirement including that
160 is about 257.
um
i have
i do have a 30 000
emergency fund what do you make of your
and i
well i i make a good living i make a
little better than 400. good for you
what do you do
i'm a dentist awesome oh now i get the
stock okay cool can you cash out of the
uh some of
the company stock
is it set up where you can get out of it
at some point they will have
when they have you know they only offer
that at certain times so
um
there's none coming up right now but i
think there will come a time
maybe in the next year or so that i
might be able to yeah okay
so here here's the thing um number one
she's done a great job i was adding up
all your numbers susan i was like
there's nothing in here that's right
there's nothing in here that just like
got a stupid arrow over the top of it i
mean you've done a great job
you know but you've identified the the
danger zone
is if some bizarre thing happened and
this one company went broke
you would lose one third of your net
worth
yes and that's that's that scared you
when you kind of looked at it that way
and thought now that that's not the end
of the world but that's why i don't want
too much in single stock like i talked
to a lady years ago
i've used this example on there many
times procter gamble she'd been with
them 38 years and she had 750 000
procter and gamble stock only when she
got ready to retire it went down to 250
000
in value
and so because she had it all in one
company she had you know that lack of
spread around that lack of
diversification made her vulnerable and
that's the only thing that scares me
here i don't think there's anything to
panic about but if you could get out of
like half of this
and still keep your bonuses when the
next time comes around i would just
because of safety
yes
and that would be my plan if i keep 250
000 i do keep that bonus which
pays me
3 500 a month yeah well then do it yeah
that's a great return and it's worth it
it's worth some risk you know but um you
know yeah i'd get out of that what do
you owe on the house again
i owe probably about 110. okay so pay
that off this year
yes i do have one other thing you're
going to probably like fall off your
chair because i told you i'm turning 60.
um i still owe 45 000 in student loans
okay
that would be you would be like a normal
dentist
warning to you young dentists okay here
you're talking to a 60 year old still
got her student loan debt so i know but
i was i was 39 when i got out of dental
school so i was old when i got out okay
so here's the deal
what do you want to enter into when
you're 70
i think if i were you i would want to
enter into zero debt including my house
and not so much tied up in the dental
practice
right and that's it do you have a plan
for retirement susan like do you have an
age you're shooting for
yeah you know i
right now i want to just cut back to
three days a week soon maybe go to two
days a week by like
65.
okay
i don't know what i would do with myself
if i wasn't well because i was gonna say
but you can do i mean you men you threw
out 70 i don't know why specifically i'm
just saying 10 years from now you know
but in five years you could have oh you
need to be there sooner than that yeah
you need to you need to get the house
paid off and get the student loan paid
off as soon as possible
i plan to do that because i have a condo
that i'm is up for sale right now and it
has a lot of equity in it okay then
that'll knock everything out and then
let's get out let's get out of the let's
have a plan to not be in
this stock at all when you hit final
retirement but not be in it as heavy
within a couple of years if you can move
out of it does that make sense okay yes
that's
that makes absolute sense and so then
you're sitting on you know you'll be
sitting on a million dollars in mutual
funds at that point and you're going to
be sitting on a million dollars worth or
close to million dollars worth of real
estate in four or five years and um and
and you've got this fabulous income so
yeah you've just done a great job kiddo
well done
oh thank you i just didn't feel like
i've been doing a very good job at all
well it all you needed was i i think all
you need is some of the rough edges
polished off
yeah so the two debt things are sloppy
and the heavy weight on the stock is
scary
yes
that's all
yeah
okay good job
thank you thanks for calling honored to
have yourself funny how much is just
perspective because when you're sitting
in it and her she's like i'm overwhelmed
up all these things and i feel like oh
gosh i still have them no no and you
look at the big picture when you're out
of it to be like well no here's the
puzzle pieces and it's pretty simple so
the perspective of money it's that's
what's helpful to always have someone
else in your life to kind of well i mean
i mean i'm intimidated about my teeth
and she's intimidated by her money so
that's that's kind of normal you know
when's the last time you've been to a
susan dennis dave
just the other day this is the ramsey
show